why am i host
500.
okay how many minutes of leeway do you
think we should give to the people
arriving late from the pizza party
zero
okay maximum brutality we just start
it feels kind of harsh though to if the
pizza party started late it feels it
feels bad to
penalize people for leaving a little bit
late i need to just give them to like
803 or something
oh sorry that's my time three minutes
past the hour yeah yeah
i i like three minutes three minutes
seems diplomatic
so
okay i'm currently doing something
that's a really bad idea which is i'm
making a last minute modification to my
lecture slides
which is guaranteed to backfire but
okay i think that works
aaron should i should i start whenever
or yeah are you recording to the cloud
or
uh your computer i don't know what i'm
doing i didn't realize i was recording
all right let me see if i can stop you
real quick
thank you
okay let me record
are you able to make me host oh god yeah
sure um hang on
there you go okay
okay go ahead awesome okay uh all right
let's see if we can
oh hang on uh can you make me a co-host
or i need uh wait do i need sharing
permissions
uh all right your co-host thank you
um
why is the screen channel working sorry
about this
hey i'm sorry there's an issue with my
privacy settings i'm gonna have to come
back uh give me one moment
okay
sorry guys we're still we're still
working out all the kinks with pathabol
and zoom
so thanks for being patient
okay let's try that again
can you now see my screen yes we okay
perfect let me see if i can get rid of
that
uh if i make this full screen all right
can you all see that
you wouldn't lose anything uh let me
collapse that
okay so sorry about the slight technical
glitch there hopefully we'll get
slightly smoother doing this over the
next couple of days
um so first welcome to the first i guess
the first official lecture in the series
of lectures that we're going to be doing
um
that uh will be we'll you know we'll
hopefully covering
the kind of major conceptual and
mathematical foundations of the world
from physics project
so there'll be a kind of series of four
lectures that cover the sort of more
mathematical side of things that i'll be
giving over the next few days
then we'll have a couple of lectures
given by myself and max
about more practical kind of software
development type things and how to use
our
our tool stack and how to actually get
started using our kind of um
the research code that we developed and
all of the function repository
entries that we've created for for doing
this physics project
and that will come kind of later on in
the week and all of that will of course
be interspersed with kind of special
topics lectures given by stephen
and other things that he's going to be
he's going to be up to so anyway
without further ado this is this is the
first lecture that's hopefully going to
cover some basic aspects of our
formalism
uh introduce this concept that we call
causal invariants that's kind of that's
fundamental to a lot of the
the ways that we think about these
models and its relationships to special
relativity
and maybe giving some hints towards the
relationship to general relativity but
that's going to really be
the topic of the next talk um but as
this is the first in the series i wanted
to begin by doing
uh what i think george bush described as
the vision thing
um but as this is liable to be at least
a little bit embarrassing i
promise i won't take more than a few
minutes of it um the basic idea is you
know so for the last
uh stephen kind of alluded to in his in
his keynote you know for the last 350
years or so since the time of people
like newton and
galileo and descartes and kepler and
others like that
there's been kind of one key
methodological idea in in the
exact sciences and in physics in
particular which is kind of you know you
go outside and you find some phenomenon
that you want to try to explain like
celestial mechanics or electromagnetism
or uh you know elementary particle
interactions or whatever
and then you uh and then you try to
drill down and find the primitives and
find the fundamentals from which you can
then build up
a quantitative mathematical model um
what we're trying to do
uh is kind of the complete inversion of
that it's a you know it's a paradigm
that was
first really proposed in a serious way
by stephen back in 2002
uh with the publication of his book a
new kind of science where instead
you know the idea is rather perversely
instead of starting from the phenomenon
drilling down and finding the model
you kind of start from the model and you
build up and you you basically enumerate
spaces of possible models
and then you you know you explicitly
compute their consequences and attempt
to do the analysis
to figure out whether there is actually
overlap between you know the things we
understand in these models
and you know what we know of actual
existing mathematical physics
so the basic idea behind our formalism
is to develop the most minimal structure
which you can use to represent candidate
laws of physics you know actually
designing a data structure
that can
is a highly succeed activity and we're
not convinced that we have the right
model
but you know it's becoming increasingly
clear that the model we do have does
still
have a lot to say about fundamental
physics and about a lot of other things
besides
stephen already alluded to so kind of
you know the basic underlying idea
is treat space not as a continuum but
actually as a very large collection of
discrete points with an adjacency
structure defined on them
by a by essentially a network structure
and then and then you can represent
possible dynamics on those candidate
universes
in terms of transformation rules between
subgraphs and those networks so each
possible transformation rule effectively
corresponds to a different candidate for
the laws of physics a different
candidate universe
and then we can just enumerate the space
of all such candidate universes and we
find
beautiful things like these and so
essentially you know the big question we
want to ask is
uh could one of these be our universe
could our universe be just lying out
there
in this computational universe of all
possible universes
and that's a pretty difficult question
to answer and it's not immediately clear
what the answer is going to be
but uh the remarkable thing that we've
discovered uh over the last several
months
is that uh there is there exist large
classes of these transformation systems
of the you know these network-based
space-time systems that
are provably compatible with many many
aspects of known kind of
mathematical physics including uh you
know special relativity
uh general relativity quantum mechanics
quantum field theory in certain
uh continuum limits um and and we're
immediately kind of
we're sort of being presented with a
bunch of really neat correspondences
between concepts like
uh path integrals and einstein hilbert
action in both quantum mechanics and
general relativity
uh correspondences between global
changes of dimension and inflationary
cosmology
as well as a bunch of implications for
things like the ads cft correspondence
the er equals epr conjecture
the black hole information paradox
holography uh lots of these other kinds
of things this is really this is a very
both a very broad and a very deep
mathematical structure
and kind of the the objective for these
uh the next few lectures
is to give you a sense of uh you know of
kind of what the key ideas are um i'm
aware that there are many of you who you
know
come from various different backgrounds
we have mathematicians and physicists
and computer scientists and other people
from
at all kinds of different levels so
inevitably i will end up saying some
things that many of you will know very
well
i may also say some things that many of
you will find completely inscrutable
um there's not a huge amount that we i'm
gonna try to do my best
to to make this as interesting and as
accessible to everyone as i possibly can
but that's kind of an impossible task
uh given given the diversity of the
audience uh but but the hope is that the
discussion sessions that we run after
the
after the fact uh will help you to to
clarify well hey hopefully uh
for those of you who find this these
lectures boring uh we'll help you to
kind of engage a bit more with the
material and for those of you who
find them totally confusing and
alienating will help you to kind of uh
to allay some of your confusions but
we'll we'll see how well that goes
anyway that's that's enough of the
vision let me let me get into the actual
content
so i mentioned you know the key idea is
uh could treat space is a very large
collection of discrete points that on a
large scale resembles continuous space
in much the same way as a large
collection of discrete molecules
resembles a continuous fluid
so back in the nks days stephen proposed
a way of doing that in terms of what are
called trivalent networks
here are some examples here so a travel
network is just a
an ordinary regular graph where every
vertex has degrees three
the reason for choosing trivalent
networks is because they're somehow
they're a universal graph representation
because if you have any arbitrary
network
you can always you can take that
arbitrary network and you can replace it
with something that's a trivalent
network but has the same large-scale
combinatorial properties
because any uh basically any vertex that
has a degree greater than three
you can you know you can replace that
with a cycle of vertices that have
degree exactly three
and then and you know they say the
large-scale property of the network is
the same
so then you know here's an example of an
evolution for one of those tribular
networks
that produces effectively a sipinski uh
tetrahedron uh this is a
geometrical structure that we'll see uh
many many times during during the
course of the next few talks um and so
this represents a possible dynamics for
a simple universe this is obviously so
simple that it couldn't possibly be our
universe
but as we saw in the previous slide
there's there's great diversity out
there even amongst a very simple
network transformation rules one of the
problems with uh the trivial network
approach though
is that that steven discovered was that
it's um
there are some sort of technical issues
when you try and define dynamics
because uh so amongst other things it
becomes a little bit tricky to figure if
you
if you do a subgraph replacement it
becomes a bit tricky to figure out how
you kind of plumb
the replaced subgraph back into the rest
of the network and effectively you you
have to
you have to have the situation where um
the the the symmetry group of the
outgoing hypergraph has to be at least
as large as the symmetry of the incoming
hypergraph as well as preserving the
number of outgoing edges
because otherwise if the symmetry group
is is reduced then uh there isn't a
unique way to kind of plumb the
resultant hypograph
the resultant subgraph back into the rem
to the rest of the trivalent network
so as a result more recently we've been
investigating a an abstract
generalization of this framework
considering not trivalent networks but
actually arbitrary hypergraphs
so what is a hypergraph well okay a
hypergraph is just it's a generalization
of
an ordinary graph in which one has
hyperedges
that can connect any arbitrary subset of
vertices or any arbitrary non-empty
subset of vertices
so uh set theoretically you can think of
a hypergraph as just being a collection
of ordered relations between abstract
elements so on the left here
here's an example of a hypergraph
corresponding to a collection of rt2
relations binary relations which is
therefore
can therefore be interpreted as an
ordinary directed graph on the right
here
is a collection of rt3 relations which
can therefore be interpreted as a
hypergraph
in which each hyperedge connects an
ordered sequence of exactly three
vertices
so these are the sort of fundamental
structures that we're trying to
investigate
so then you define a dynamics on these
hypergraphs by saying basically if you
have a piece of the hypergraph that
looks like this then you can replace it
with a piece of the hypograph that looks
like that
um and and this uh having having this
general formulation in terms of set
substitution systems where you're
basically saying
if you have a collection of ordered
relations between elements
and it contains a subset that matches a
particular pattern then replace it with
a subset matching a different pattern
that the generality of that construction
means you get around a lot of these
these symmetry problems you would
otherwise have in these more constrained
trivalent network models
so effectively each such each sub
updating rule each such
uh hypergraph transformation rule or set
substitution system defines a different
candidate dynamics for the hypograph
so then if you just take an a simple
initial hypergraph like this sort of
double self loop here and you apply
uh you apply the you know for instance
this particular transformation rule
in all of the places where it applies uh
effectively trying to update every uh
every hyperedge uh simultaneously
without overlaps you
construct kind of the maximally
non-overlapping sequence of
of update operations then you get an
evolution that looks something like this
and so so this is the so here it is
after 10 steps of evolution after 14
steps of evolution
you get this more complicated looking
thing here and at a large scale
many classes you know many instances of
these hypergraphs have kind of
effectively uh
bulk geometry that is quite like the
geometry of romanian manifolds in fact
in certain cases we can prove are
exactly the geometries of
romanian manifolds uh which is you know
one of the things i want to sort of
discuss in the course of these lectures
so this is kind of this is the
underlying model that we're
investigating
as a candidate for a model for our
universe now obviously at first it seems
a little bit crazy that something this
simple could actually reproduce anything
like existing physics
uh what i want to try to convince you of
today is that you know a major feature
of our universe namely special
relativity
uh emerges as a very natural consequence
of these hypography writing systems
with things like general relativity and
gravitation and other things
uh which i'll discuss tomorrow i think i
i forget where my next lecture is but i
think it's i think it's tomorrow morning
okay so one concern that you might very
reasonably have if you're presented with
this formalism is
uh what what is the canonical updating
order for one of these models right
if you if you're presented with a
hypergraph like that and a replacement
rule like this
then you know there are canonically many
many possible places where that rule
could get applied
and each place where you apply the rule
will place constraints on other places
where you can apply the rule
and so each sort of initial choice of
updating event uh
corresponds to a different choice of
updating order and in general different
choices of updating order will lead to
distinct kind of non-isomorphic spatial
hypergraphs
and that's sort of a problem um because
it means that uh you know
that in effect uh you you won't have
deterministic evolution of the system
so the first question you might ask is
well how do we get around that problem
so that's what i kind of want to discuss
here
so uh it turns out you know the main
thing that's kind of observationally
accessible
is not the hypograph itself but the
sequence of
but sorry or the particular set of
causal relationships between the
updating events
so what matters is the sequencing of
events in time as opposed to the strict
kind of space like separation of the
events themselves
so in other words given a sequence of
applications of updating events we can
ask which updating events
you know are causally dependent on which
other updating events which
or in other words uh if you applied a
rule at a particular place and you call
that event b
uh could event b have been applied if a
previous event a hadn't already been
applied
so to represent those causal relations
we construct this thing called a causal
network which is a directed acyclic
graph
where the collection of vertices is the
collection of updating events
and in which the each directed edge
between vertices a and b
exists if and only if uh event b could
only have been applied if event a had
previously been applied
and so from a kind of pragmatic point of
view the way we can work that out
is we say if the input for event a has a
non-trivial overlap with the output of
event
uh the input for event b has a
non-trivial overlap with the output of
event a
uh then we know that there's a causal
relation because effectively that's
saying
uh event the input for event b is making
use of uh of nodes that were produced by
the output of event a and therefore
obviously event b couldn't have been
applied unless
that a had been applied and so then you
construct effectively a partial a causal
partial order
and then the causal network you can
think of as being the husser diagram or
the
the transitive reduction of the huster
diagram for that causal partial order
and so you get this thing
that looks like this so each one of
these sort of pale yellow boxes here is
a representation of an updating event
that's transforming one subtype of graph
into a different subtypograph and each
orange edge
is denoting a causal relationship
between those updating events so we know
this event couldn't have been applied
unless this event and this event had
both previously been applied
and so the sort of the speculation the
suggestive speculation
is that this causal network of the its
transitive reduction
corresponds to has to the huster diagram
for the causal partial order on some
discrete approximation to a lorenzian
manifold
just like you can define a causal
partial order in ordinary uh general
relativity by considering the sort of
topological properties of lawrencium
manifold
and so that again that's something we're
going to discuss in a minute
so then really the question about uh
what about all of these different
choices of updating order how do you get
around the fact that there are many
canonical choices of updating order
that question effectively becomes how do
we guarantee that the causal network the
particular causal partial order that we
see
is always unique is always the same so
because there are many different
possible evolution histories generically
you won't see a single thread of
evolution you'll see a non-deterministic
evolution
where effectively the universe
bifurcates at all these different places
and there's actually a whole directed
acyclic graph or you know or
a merging tree uh that sort of
parameterizes all of the possible
evolution orders so this produces a
thing
that we call the multi-way evolution
graph which you see here so every every
blue node here
is a specification of a hypergraph every
uh every gray edge is an application of
an updating event and so the multi-way
evolution graph is parameterizing the
set of all possible updating orders
that you could apply to that hypergraph
and showing what you what you obtain and
of course the you know the merging
criterion
for for two nodes in the multi-way
evolution graph is the isomorphism of
the underlying hypergraphs
so given that we given that the the
evolution is actually not a path but
rather this
this directed acyclic graph how can we
possibly get deterministic behavior
um well okay this is this is
illustrating a particular choice of path
a particular choice of updating order
which actually is the choice of updating
order that we saw here
so the the there is nothing particularly
special about this particular choice of
updating order it's just some random
updating order we picked that happen to
be valid and non-overlapping
and consistent with the causal partial
order but you can see there are also all
of these other different valid updating
orders that will yield different
non-isomorphic spatial hypergraphs
and again skipping ahead a bit the
statement that there isn't a canonical
updating order for these wolfram model
systems
corresponds in the relativistic case to
the statement that there is no canonical
reference frame in our universe
okay so in order so the way we get
around this is by
imposing this property that we call
causal invariance that as i say is a
really fundamental thing that
it's you know it's quite important to
understand uh if you if you really want
to kind of get your head around what
these models are doing
uh before i can really explain causal
and variance i'm going to introduce a
bit of sort of terminology
and machinery that comes from
mathematical logic and particularly from
an area called abstract rewriting theory
so an abstract rewriting theory an
abstract rewriting system or an ars
is just a set which we'll call a where
every element is an object
and a binary relation which we'll call
arrow which is known as the rewrite
relation and so the intuition is uh in
the case of a wolfer model system if we
formulated it as an ars
the set of objects would be that you
know the set a would be the set of all
possible hypographs
and the rewrite relation is the
specification that a particular
hypergraph
can be rewritten as a different one
using a particular rule and so
in this case uh each each directed edge
in the multi-way evolution graph
corresponds to an
instance of this binary rewrite relation
of the ars
so given that rewrite relation we can
define its reflexive transitive closure
which we'll call arrow star
in other words it's the transitive
closure of the union of the rewrite
relation with the identity relation
and so what that's saying if you say
okay so as i say if you say a arrows b
in the wolfram model case that's saying
hypergraph a can be directly rewritten
as hypergraph b
if you say a arrow star b that's
indicating that either a and b are
isomorphic
or there exists not a single updating
event but actually a finite
updating sequence a sequence of updating
operations that connects
a to b so in other words you know this
we could say this hypograph arrow stars
this hypograph
because there exists this finite rewrite
sequence that connects one to the other
or
to be a bit more precise this vertex
lies strictly in the out component of
this other vertex
that's what uh that's what the reflexive
transitive closure is so it's the
smallest pre-order
that that uh that contains arrows so
it's a binary relation
that uh satisfies both reflectivity and
transitivity and is kind of minimal
with respect to those properties okay so
then
given that we can introduce this concept
in mathematical logic called confluence
i think in older mathematical logic
texts it's known as the church roster
property
because i think alonzo church and jay
barclay ross approved it for the case of
untyped lambda calculus back in 1936
but essentially confluence uh gives you
this
intuitively gives you this idea that uh
that the order of application doesn't
matter in some very precise sentence
um so what it means is that for any
bifurcation that you see in the
multi-way evolution graph like this
bifurcation here
there is eventually a resolution as you
can see in you know when when these two
hypergraphs
sorry that hypograph they're in that
hotter graph they're uh resolved to
yield this hypergraph here
we could describe this element as being
a confluent element or a complement
object
uh because any anytime there's a
bifurcation any time there's a rewrite
sequence
leading from a to b and a to c there's
also a common element d
in their kind of future light cone uh to
which both b and c
uh resolve uh and so if all of the
elements in the rewrite system are
complement then we can say that the
overall system is confluent or has this
church roster property
so here's an example of a multi-way
evolution graph for a for a system that
we can immediately see as confluent
uh is globally confluent because you can
see that for every bifurcation they
eventually resolve back to
a common element within a single step
now
there's no requirement that they resolve
back within a single step they could
take arbitrarily many steps to resolve
this is why the prop the problem of
determining complements of an arbitrary
multi-way system is hard in fact it's
it's provably undecidable in the general
case
but nevertheless in certain simple cases
like in the case of one step convergence
we do have ways of determining it uh
okay so so global confluence as i say is
one
very precise sense in which we could say
if you have a globally confluent rewrite
system
the order of application of updating
events doesn't matter um
it's the the interesting thing is that
confluence is a is a sufficient
condition
sorry confidence is a necessary
condition sorry for uh
for this much more general and powerful
property that we call causal invariance
so causes and variance is the statement
that all of the causal networks that get
generated by each branch to the
multi-way evolution graph
ultimately end up being isomorphic as
directed acyclic graphs so in other
words
it kind of doesn't matter which which
updating order you choose
the causal network you end up with is
always unique up to isomorphism
so not only is confluence a necessary
condition for causal variants but
moreover and perhaps more excitingly
uh causal and variance is a sufficient
conviction for lorentz symmetry uh which
of course is the basis of special
relativity and so
the the you know the basic idea is uh
whenever you have a causal invariant
rewrite system a causal and variable for
model system
you immediately have satisfaction of
special relativity uh and i'll i'm going
to walk you through
basically how that argument works um by
the way the claim that
uh confluence is a is a is a sort of
necessary condition for causal variants
that's a pretty sort of uh i think
that's a pretty instructive exercise to
do
i already i think gave some hints about
how to do it on slack but um yeah the
basic idea is
if you uh if you consider the kind of
base case in which you have an
elementary bifurcation in the multi-way
system and then demonstrate that the
causal networks you get for
those two for the for the um bifurcation
that doesn't uh sort of reconverge
if you show explicitly just by computing
it that the two uh
causal networks you get out are
non-isomorphic then
you can just then you can prove the
claim in general given that base case
you can prove the claim in general
uh by just doing strong induction on the
set of all possible possible updating
events
uh like i say i highly encourage you to
do to do the exercise if you're if you
want to kind of figure out if you want
to get better intuition for the
relationship
between global confluence and the
property of causeland variants
so uh okay to make that a little bit
less abstract here's an example of a
multi-system where you can explicitly
see this correspondence
so this is a multi-way causal network
now so you can see we have update
updating events in in yellow connected
by uh causal relations in orange but we
also have states uh
individual hypographs that we color in
blue connected by evolution edges that
we color in in gray
and so in this particular case you can
see the system is confluent because when
you have a bifurcation it immediately
kind of
reconverges in fact we we know that it's
one step confluent
but moreover we can see that it's
actually causal and variant because you
you can
you by just explicitly tracing out each
path you can see that for the four
possible evolution paths through the
system
the causal network you get out the you
know the particular sequence of causal
relationships that you observe
that you kind of peel off from the
system are always the same in fact in
this case they happen to be always
trivial they're always just path graphs
uh consisting of four updating events
connected by three causal edges
okay so that's a bit about the sort of
the correspondence between uh global
confluence and this property that we
call causal and variance the property
that
the causal network is always unique uh
independent of the updating order
um there are a bunch of i i happen to
formulate this in terms of this
particular field of mathematical logic
which is abstract rewriting theory
there are a bunch of other ways you can
formulate effectively the same idea um
i'm not really an expert in category
theory but there is a you know i did fig
i know enough to be able to kind of
figure out
a basic category theoretic
representation of the same idea so if
you think about this rewrite relation
arrow
you can if you think about it instead as
being an indexed union of sub-relations
then what you end up with is this
computational object which is a labeled
state transition system
and so that so that system is then a
bijective function from the set of
objects in the rewrite system
to the power set of that set of objects
are you know the set of all possible
subsets
that's indexed by the by the labels and
so then what you end up with is this
thing called an fco algebra
uh for for the for that for that power
set functor
um but again i let me not go into too
much detail
into the sort of precise category
theoretical formulation although i'm
happy to discuss it with
any of you who kind of know a bit about
category theory i mean but the basic
idea being
then once you have a categorical
representation of the multi-way
evolution graph and
in particular when you think of the
rewrite system as being an endo function
on the category of sets
then uh effectively what happens is uh
the the statement of global confluence
becomes a statement that for every
uh for every cone in the associated
category there is a corresponding cocoon
which corresponds to the statement that
you know anytime there's a bifurcation
in the multi-evolution graph
there's an associated convergence and so
uh i'm here i'm just trying to
illustrate that there are a few
different ways you can formulate the
same idea of confluence
but they are all kind of ultimately
formally equivalent
another way you can think about the same
idea as i mentioned is in the context of
this thing called the the untyped lambda
calculus and computability theory
so if again for those of you who know
about lambda calculus
you know if you when when you do sort of
when you do beta reduction and you
you replace the so the bound variables
you get by doing alpha conversion if you
then replace them in the body of the
abstraction you get effectively a
rewrite operation between lambda terms
and then the statement the two lambda
terms are equivalent becomes it becomes
itself equivalent to the statement that
the two landed terms are
joinable in the sense that there exists
a common lambda term
for which the two uh lambda terms x and
y are both reducible
and that's again a statement of sort of
convergence between uh between
bifurcations in a multi-way system
and so uh the you know the the claim
that the church also
the claim that lambda calculus exhibits
the church roster property
is exactly the claim that this rewrite
system satisfies global confluence
and therefore you know subject to some
additional assumptions is also a causal
invariant system
so um the the the main thing i kind of
want to get across in in saying all of
that
is that causal invariance is a very
general property of computational
systems it's not specific to hypergraph
systems
but in our case where we're considering
hypergraph systems
it happens to be a great interest
because of its relation to special
relativity
um again these are some ideas that i'll
discuss in more detail in the quantum
mechanics lectures
because they turn out to be very very
important uh for our understanding of
quantum mechanics and in particular of
quantum measurement um and in
understanding the relationship between
quantum mechanics
and special relativity but uh there are
in addition to global confluence which i
already described
there are several modifications to that
property so you could consider a concept
like local confluence where you're
saying
any divergence that happens after a
single step have to divert
you know have to converge after an
arbitrary rewrite sequence that's a kind
of weaker form of global confluence
that's only equivalent to um
local confluence and global confluence
have equivalence when the when the
system is is
fairly simple but in more complicated
systems where you have when you don't
have guaranteed termination
they become quite different then there
are also concepts like semi-confluence
where
effectively one of your elements of the
bifurcation is produced by a single
updating event
and the other is produced by an
arbitrary sequence of updating events
and again they're forced to converge
there are also ways you can strengthen
the property like the strong diamond
property where you know effectively
every every bifurcation has to
reconverge within a single step we
actually saw an explicit example of that
here this is an example of a
rewrite system that's not just causal
invariant but it also satisfies the
stronger condition of the strong diamond
property
and things like strong confluence which
is which is the property that when you
have
objects diverging after a single rewrite
relation rewrite operation at least one
of them has to converge after no more
than one additional rewrite operation
that's weaker than the strong diamond
property
but still stronger than global
confluence anyway again that's
kind of a kind of an aside i just kind
of wanted to i wanted to place those
ideas in your head
in kind of preparation for the quantum
mechanics lectures because uh we'll
we'll discuss that in
much more detail then so here's the
basic point
okay so uh different choices of updating
orders are effectively
you are different choices of you know
which updating events you want to apply
and so in particular you know as i say
when you when you want to evolve the
system in time
you want to apply the maximally
non-overlapping set of updating events
the maximally
uh sort of non-overlapping space-like
separated set of updating events
on the hypergraph but generically there
are many such possible choices there are
many possible choices of updating order
so each one of them correspond you can
think of as corresponding to a different
foliation
of the causal network because as i say
the you know the causal network consists
of these updating events that are the
vertices and these cause ledges that are
the
the the the that are the the um sorry
the causal relations that are the edges
of the causal network
uh the you know the relations in the
partial order and so
by foliating the causal network by
splitting it up into an equivalence
class
of different uh updating events uh that
are considered to be simultaneous with
respect to some observer
uh each possible choice of foliation
corresponds to a different possible
choice
of space of sort of consistent space
like separated updating events
space like separated updating events
that are non-overlapping
and therefore consistent with the causal
partial order and so
uh the statement of causal and variance
therefore becomes the
statement that the combinatorial
structure of the causal network is
invariant under different choices of
foliation
so here's a particular choice of
foliation with a particular sequence of
hypergraphs that you see you know
as seen by this particular observer
here's a different choice of foliation
that's still perfectly valid it's a
perfectly
you know it's still consistent with the
causal partial order and so it's another
valid choice of updating order for this
particular hypergraph rewrite system
but you can see it produces a different
sequence of hypergraphs so in particular
you know like here that the third
hypograph you see in this
rewrite sequence is clearly
non-isomorphic to the third hypograph
seen in this rewrite sequence
but nevertheless because the because of
causal and variants
we know that independent of the updating
order the structure of the causal
network its pure combinatorial structure
is always the same you know so the
causal network is unique
up to isomorphous so as i mentioned
because you can think of the causal
network as being like the
a representation of the of the causal
structure the conformally invariant
structure of some larency and manifold
uh what we're really saying is that the
causal network uh
and well because because the causal
structure of such a manifold is is the
is exactly the conformally invariant
structure
and because causal invariance is saying
that that combinatorial structure is
unique under any parameterized change of
observer
under any parameterized uh change in in
the choice of updating order
what you end up with is the statement
that effectively the combinatorial
structure of the causal network
is invariant under the action of the
conformal group and so because both the
lorentz group and the pancari group
are subgroups of the conformal group one
immediately determines that one has both
lorentz symmetry
and pancari symmetry both of which are
important for special relativity and
general relativity respectively
in fact we've actually shown a slightly
stronger thing it turns out
and again this will be a topic that we
cover in the general relativity lecture
tomorrow
but not only is causal invariant
sufficient for proving
lorenz symmetry it's also sufficient for
proving local lorentz symmetry and in
fact weakened versions of the
the principle of general covariance
which is kind of the basis of the
generalistic derivation
okay so um that is kind of that's the
high-level picture of how special
relativity works in the context of these
models it's just a sort of
an immediate consequence of the
principle of causal and variance of the
principle that
the causal structure of the of the of
the discrete approximation to the
manifold
is invariant under different choices of
foliation and different choices of
observer um
one concern that you might have that's a
purely kind of mathematical one
is we kind of we did a bit of sleight of
hand here by introducing this notion
of a causal network foliation without
really explaining what it is as i say
it's kind of it's an equivalence class
of
of different updating events in the
causal network uh so that's ordered in
time
but um to be a bit more precise what we
can what we
what we're doing when we construct these
foliations is we're assuming that the
causal network is is uh
associated to what you might call a
globally hyperbolic spacetime in other
words we're assuming that there exists a
universal time function which we'll call
t
that effectively maps from the updating
events in the causal network
onto integers that correspond to the
particular layer of the foliation on
which that updating event lies
such that uh delta t is non-zero
everywhere in in other words such that
uh these these uh space like hyper
surfaces
don't sort of trivially intersect there
has to exist at least one
causal edge between a particular
updating event on one hypersurface
and the kind of corresponding updating
event on the neighboring hypersurface
uh and we're also saying that the this
choice of universal time function
effectively foliates the causal network
into a parametric family
of non-intersecting spaces like
hypersurfaces uh which are the level
sets
of that universal time function so each
one of these things here you can think
of as being the level set
of the function that's mapping uh
updating events in the causal network
onto values of the universal time
function
um so then to really understand how we
know what these what these defoliations
are and how we can parameterize them and
how we can think about them
we we make extensive use of of the
techniques of geometric quantization in
canonical hamiltonian quantum gravity
and so there's this there's this concept
that exists in canonical uh sort of
hamiltonian gr
which is of the adm decomposition the
adm formalism
where the the basic idea is uh the way
you parameterize the
you know you take your your uh the
varenicity and manifold your space-time
manifold and you foliate it into this
into the level sets of this universal
time function and then locally the way
you describe that foliation
is by making a gauge choice and it turns
out we can make it we can make a
discretized version of exactly the same
gauge choice
that one does in standard adm relativity
uh in the context of these causal
networks
so essentially what you have to note is
that uh the hypergraph comes equipped
with essentially a natural distance
metric a
a combinatorial distance metric so any
any two nodes that appear in the
hypograph
uh you know they will naturally be
separated by a certain number of hyper
edges so you can define
a delta l like effectively a norm
between those between those
a metric between those uh between those
hypernodes that is
the number of hyper edges one has to
traverse to get from this part of the
hypergraph to this other part of the
hypograph
um and so uh in doing that
uh one is effectively implicitly
defining a kind of discrete spatial
metric tensor which we can call gamma i
j
in terms of this this natural choice of
metric delta l
um and this so this gives us a natural
coordinates a quadratization or at least
a local quadratization
of the hypergraph and and moreover one
also has a quadratization of the actual
time evolution
because we can define uh time you know
we can define lapses we can define
intervals in time just in terms of if
you want to know the interval
of time between two updating events in
the causal network
you can just count the number of causal
edges that separate them in in some path
and so effectively what you can do
locally on each hypersurface
is define a discrete lapse function that
tells you effectively how many causal
edges do you have to traverse
between this updating event and the next
updating event and you can also define a
shift vector
that tells you effectively it's right so
the lapse function is effectively giving
you
the time like distance the time-like
separation between
the local parts of those two
hypersurfaces and then you can also
define a shift vector
that tells you effectively the
space-like separation so what you're
really asking is
uh what is the what is the dis the
natural distance on the hypograph
between the place where this updating
event got applied
and the place where this future updating
event gets applied and so by defining a
discrete lapse function
and a discrete shift vector for every
updating event on the current foliation
of the causal network
you completely determine the future
foliation of the causal the you know the
the next
uh the next hypersurface in that
particular foliation and so by taking
uh all points in space-time all points
on the causal network and assigning them
a discrete lapse
and a discrete shift we successfully
parameterize the complete foliation of
the space time and therefore
uh you know the the the complete uh the
complete specification of the observer
so by again by analogy to ordinary
general relativity
you can think of uh you know this
particular gauge choice is the gauge
choice being made by a local
normal observer an observer moving uh
with respect to geodesic normal
coordinates
in the kind of in the flow of time and
so by combining these together so
this is our specification of the of the
relationship between the spatial
coordinate system
and the shift vector beta this is the
relationship between the time coordinate
system and the
uh the lapse function alpha and so
together they give us an overall line
element a space-time line element for
the overall causal network that looks
like this it's this discrete line
element
uh with this particular form so that's
you know that's effectively what we're
doing when we talk about these causal
network foliations
each foliation is to say is a is a
particular choice of updating order
corresponding to a particular choice of
observer
and where the choice of observer can
effectively be parameterized
by making a local gauge choice of lapse
function and shift vector
at every point in space time
okay so um this also so
one important thing that i i really
ought to say is you know i could kind of
leave the leave the derivation there
right
it's all the pieces are kind of in place
the you you you know that the
you know the system we're dealing with
is causal invariant so there is a unique
causal network up to isomorphism and so
under any parameterized change of
observer
the combinatorial structure of the
causal network is always the same and so
in particular
what you're really saying is even though
the ordering of space-like separated
updating events can change
the ordering of time-like separated
updating events is always preserved
which is precisely
precisely the statement of lorentz
symmetry and so
the state and furthermore the statement
that the hypergraph replacement rules
have
fixed size and so you can't get
propagation of information faster than
the you know
the hypograph itself can evolve gives
you a natural speed of light and so you
immediately have the two fundamental
postulates of special relativity and we
have
everything we need to prove uh local
rent symmetry which is i say just kind
of trivially follows
from from the principle of causal and
variance uh so i could kind of leave the
derivation there
but in the interests of not being
totally obscure let me uh let me
actually
give you a little bit more detail about
how you can see a kind of toy case of
this
uh for yourself kind of in a more
explicit way um i i should mention that
this you know
this derivation of the more explicit
case uh is is a very
this is very much a toy example it's a
naive example it only works in certain
numbers of dimensions
and it requires a sort of an embedding
algorithm that is not that you know that
doesn't generalize
uh but doing this derivation in the
general case as i say effectively
requires considering the action of the
conformal group
uh in the way that i just described so
what if uh
if we consider now we take a causal
network and we just make a really really
naive choice of norm
so what we're going to do is we're going
to we're going to do construct we're
going to take the causal network
we construct a layered digraph embedding
into into so we're taking this directed
acyclic graph we're constructing
constructing a layered embedding into
the plane which we can do because we
know that the system is globally
hyperbolic
and so if it's globally hyperbolic we
know that there don't exist close
time-like curves
and so that you know there's there's no
place where the where the layer digraph
embedding is going to fail
so in other words we we guarantee that
we can embed the directed graph
uh in such a way that all of the causal
edges point monotonically downwards
so given that layered embedding you can
then induce a geometry so you can think
of that embedding as being
as being embedding into some lattice z1n
and given that embedding you can
describe you can make an uh sort of a
very naive choice of norm
which is just the the space-like
distance uh you know the
the the natural hyper graph distance uh
my squared
uh minus the the the time-like distance
squared so in other words between any
two updating events
you can just compute what is the what is
the distance this distance in the
spatial hypergraph between the places
where those updating events got applied
square it and subtract the time-like
separation the causal edge distance
between those two events in the causal
network and you immediately get
a very naive kind of discrete
approximation to the minkowski norm with
respect to this space
um and and then of course we we
immediately get a sort of
classification of events we can classify
events as being time-like like like
or or space-like depending on whether
they're their sort of discrete minkowski
norm
is negative zero or positive
respectively
and then uh that that of course
corresponds exactly to the sort of
intuition we have about these causal
networks
that a pair of updating events are
time-like separated or causally related
if and only if they're connected by a
finite path with respect to the causal
network
um they are sort of they are light like
separated if they're if they're
time-like but somehow extremal so that
they lie on the boundary of a light cone
rather than on the interior
and again we can show some explicit
examples of exactly what that means in a
minute
um and that they are space-like
separated if they're not
if they're not uh light-like or or light
or time-like so in other words
uh you know these events here are
space-like separated because they're not
directly connected
by any path in the causal network
there's no causal dependence of this
event on that event and that's why we're
allowed to construct a foliation
in which we consider those causal events
those updating events
as being simultaneous events being
applied to the spatial hypograph at the
same time
without any kind of overlap or violation
because because
that particular that choice of local
updating order uh is still consistent
with the causal partial order
um okay so so like i say then then based
on whether the uh
uh norm distance between uh a pair of
updating events
is time-like light-like or space-like
you then immediately get this notion of
of time-like light-like and space-like
separation
uh the particular of course the
particular choice of foliation uh
and therefore the particular choice of
layered digraph embedding uh
sort of trades off which which parts of
the
which parts of the multi-wave and kovski
norm are treated as being spatial parts
and which parts are treated as being
time-like parts um and so that's then uh
that means therefore that you know the
structure of your light cones locally
uh is is dependent on the foliation as
we'll see in a minute
um so then uh this gives us another way
once you have the notion of of the sort
of the embedding of the causal network
into this
uh into this lattice and then you have
this notion of a very naive minkowski
norm defined on it
this gives us a a different a more
concrete way of thinking about what
these
uh what these space like hypersurfaces
are we can think of them as being like
the discrete analog of koshi surfaces
for a for a time evolution problem so in
other words
their set of updating events so that
every time like or light-like path
effectively every
uh every uh finite path in the causal
network of uh consisting of
uh you know events connected by causal
ledgers uh intersects
an updating event that exists in that
surface exactly once
which is another way of saying that the
system is kind of locally hyperbolic
so that you don't have kind of loops or
weird situations where the path kind of
stays on the hypersurface for a bit and
then
diverges out if it's globally hyperbolic
everything is pointing monotonically
downwards
and so you can you can guarantee that
this uh you know this kosher surface has
every time-like and light-like path
intersecting it exactly once
and so this is a this is a more formal
way of saying that it's a it's a locally
hyperbolic kind of
hypersurface existing in the foliation
in which every pair of updating events
is strictly space-like separated
so given that sort of uh given that
notion of a um
of a koshi problem with respect to the
causal network we immediately get you
know all of the standard differential
topology techniques that come from
general relativity and that come from
uh the analysis of of you know lorenzi
and space times and so on uh
this whole concept of causal structure
of lawrencie and manifold
we can kind of import all of those
techniques from ordinary general
relativity to the discrete case of our
causal networks
and you know and because the because the
causal partial order of our causal
network
is really a discrete approximation to
the causal partial order of a continuous
laryngeal manifold
unsurprisingly all of the properties of
causal structure and conformal structure
are sort of naturally naturally port
over to the causal network case
so in this in this instance we can say
if there exists a chronological path but
connecting a pair of updating events in
the causal network
then we that is future directed so in
which every causal edge points
monotonically downwards
then we can say that one one of those
updating events str you know strictly
chronologically proceeds or one of those
updating if it's yeah
if the case of a of a uh
wait sorry i've i've mistyped this this
should say causally causally proceeds i
got confused for a moment yeah so we so
in the case where there exists a
chronological path
a path consisting of um uh purely of
uh sequences of causal edges that lie
within a light cone then we can say that
one one of those updating events uh
chronologically precedes the other we
can say that one strictly causally
precedes the other
if there is a non-space-like path so in
other words if there's a chronological
path
or a time-like path uh a
chronological path or a or light-like
path that exists at the boundary of the
light cone
that that connects those up-taking
events and we can say that it caught
it it non-strictly causally one event
non-strictly causally precedes the other
if either one strictly causally proceeds
the other or the two updating events are
actually equivalent
so that gives us a way of defining
essentially a conformal structure
uh on the causal network um and then you
know all of the step
all the properties that are so difficult
to prove in standard general relativity
to do with uh causal and conformal
structure
like the fact that the like the the fact
that chronological both chronological
and causal precedence are transitive
that becomes an immediate consequence
of the fact that the causal network as i
said right at the beginning is a
transitive reduction graph
so in which you know effectively one has
transitivity more or less
uh axiomatically um so then given a
notion of
chronological future chronological past
causal feature causal past you can
introduce notions of uh
uh of of the future and past of
individual events
so uh you know the the unsurprisingly if
you pick an updating event in the causal
network
you can think of its chronological
future as being the set of all updating
events that you can reach by a finite
uh sort of time-like path uh for a
chronological evolution
path uh following on from that updating
event its chronological future
is the set of events that exist sort of
in in its uh in its past light cone
um and so it with respect to the causal
network you can define all of these
properties purely combinatorially
so if you uh you know in other words if
you pick the if you pick an updating
event
the its total future light cone so in
other words the combination of its
chronological and causal future
is just the at the vertex out component
of that causal vertex
and it's uh it's the union of its
chronological and causal past
is simply the in component of that
particular causal vertex and so you know
concepts like future and past light
cones uh become really very very easy to
sort of represent using using this
combinatorial structure
so if the chronological future is sort
of strictly the interior of the light
cone
of course the causal future is is the is
both the interior and exterior we can
define that both for
individual updating events and the
causal network x we can also define it
of course for
for finite collections of updating
events in which case we get a whole
collection of updates
a collection of of of light cones as
opposed to just a single light cone from
a single event
so as i say you can think of the the uh
the chronological future i plus
as being purely the interior of the cone
and the causal future j
plus as being both the interior and the
boundary of the cone so here's an
explicit example
of you know of a future light cone that
you can construct in a causal network in
this case not for a
hypergraph substitution system but
actually for a simpler one-dimensional
string substitution system
so here we pick an event like this and
we just say what is its out component we
can just color
all of the vertices in the causal
network that are in the out component
and then we can say okay all of the
paths in this causal network
that are extremal that effectively lie
at the boundary of that out component
we can think of as being the those are
effectively our light-like paths those
are the those are the boundaries
uh those are the things that are
included in the causal future and then
the strict interior those are
our evolutionary paths those are our
chronological paths
and that you know so so those aspects
correspond to the chronological future
of the updating event but
but are not part uh but but you know the
the things lying on the boundary are not
part of the chronological
uh future of that that event so this is
the case you know this is an
illustration of the case for a
for a future like code uh for the case
of a past light cone it works in
much the same way just with the edges
flipped around
um and again you know just like we have
the you know the standard algebraic
properties of of the
of causal and chronological precedence
we also have the standard algebraic
properties of causal and chronological
future
which again uh holds sort of
combinatorially so because because we're
defined
because we we more or less define the
chronological paths
as being a strict superset of the set of
all causal paths
uh you know again this is this is
another example of a claim which is
quite hard to prove in differential
topology
but which holds more or less trivially
uh in the case of a causal network
so given that uh we can um we have a
more precise way of talking about the
the both the foliation of the causal
network
and a more mathematically formal way of
describing what it means for the for the
system to be globally hyperbolic and
therefore
for it to have a well-posed koshi
problem so we can say
uh if you know given a particular uh a
set of a collection of updating events
then you you can take the set of all the
updating events uh in which
all the all the past directed causal uh
paths so in
all the past directed paths that are
either chronological or
light-like intersect an updating event
that lies in that set at least once that
gives us the notion of a discrete future
koshi development and again if we if we
consider the same but with past change
to future
then we can we can uh this gives us a
notion of a discrete past koshi
development as well
and then the discrete koshi development
for a particular set of events
is then the union of the future and past
koshi developments so if you're given a
space like a hypersurface
in the causal network if you're given a
particular sort of collection of
updating events that are considered to
be space like separated
then you can then you can construct koji
development uh with respect to that
particular collection of events
just like you would in ordinary
relativity um
and so then a a koshi surface which is
our notion of a space like hypersurface
is then an acronym set of updating
events whose koshi development is the
whole
uh is the whole manifold is the whole
causal network and where acronym just
means that
uh the event is not in its own uh
chronological future
um so in other words you can't have uh
either closed time-like curves
or degenerate cases of close time-like
curves where there are sort of causal
ledgers that
don't correspond to time evolution um so
and then as a global hyperbolicity is
then of course the the statement
that there exists a discrete cauchy
surface with respect to the causal
network
so then uh i can flesh out in a bit more
detail this argument about how you know
therefore causal and variance implies
the symmetry um
even though as i say it's kind of a
pretty elementary argument
what it's really saying is that the um
because in in standard
differential topology the causal
structure of the lawrencium manifold is
invariant under a conformal rescaling so
in other words if you take the metric
and you apply a conformal factor omega
and you get this new
metric g hat um the time like null and
space like qualities of each of
vectors are invariant under that map so
in other words the set of events that
are considered to be
space like separated or time-like
separated won't change
and obviously in special cases when you
consider purely inertial reference
frames and so on
that immediately implies that uh you
know even though the space-like
separations between events can change
orderings of time like separated events
don't change which is precisely
which because the you know the causal
edges correspond to the
the or the time-like orderings of of
updating events is precisely the claim
of causal invariance so we have this
this very neat equivalence to uh between
the notion of the
uh the manifold the conformal structure
of the manifold or the causal structure
of the manifold
being invariant under a conformal
transformation and the causal network
being invariant
under parameterized changes of observers
so this is what i this is kind of
in more detail this is precisely what i
meant when i said uh causal invariance
is equivalent
to the claim that the combinatorial
structure of the causal network is
invariant under the action of the
conformal group at least in some
continuum limit
um so uh why did i why did i go through
all the trouble of defining this very
naive
sort of minkowski discrete minkowski
norm um
i i will tomorrow in the general
relativity lecture i will go
through in more detail how you can go
about defining a less naive norm
that doesn't depend on dimensionality
assumptions and doesn't depend on an
embedding in
in some lattice and all these other
things but the reason i wanted to give
you at least a
a sort of a basic norm to start off with
is because it then gives you a very nice
intuition
for how all of your favorite uh aspects
of special relativity
uh like you know all the standard
physical consequences of lorenz
transformations
start to emerge so uh again in ordinary
special relativity if you have two sort
of inertial reference frames
f and f hat and such that you know f is
is considered to be
uh to be the sort of is the is the rest
frame relative to which you're measuring
velocities
f hat is moving at some constant
velocity v relative to the rest frame
then uh you can define its its direction
of motion uh
as some some unit vector and then its
magnitude of motion is given by a
hyperbolic tangent of this quantity
rho which we can which will sort of
canonically rescale to be less than one
corresponding to the statement that the
velocity is subliminal
um and then you know assuming that the
two coordinate frames are initially
synchronized at the at the starting
point at the point where the where the
time functions are the same
then the lorentz transformation is the
thing that gives you a way of expressing
the coordinates on f prime
in terms of the coordinates on f and so
because we have a coordination
of the spatial hypograph and the causal
network we can do exactly the same thing
in our models we can
given uh two particular choices of
foliation of the causal network
we can construct the lorenz
transformation that the the uh
a discrete analog of the transformation
that rewrites
the coordination of that of the of the f
prime foliation
in terms of the original rest frame
coordinatization of the f foliation and
the
so that the lorentz transformation looks
like this that gives us a way of
translating
between two between the quadratizations
corresponding to two different
uh layered digraph embeddings of the
causal network
so if we want to see an explicit example
of how we do that if you consider
you know the basic two-dimensional case
let's think about this hypograph rule
here
this happens to be a very very simple
hypograph transformation rule that
constructs a a sort of a a
a simple one-dimensional hypograph that
then induces a kind of a very very basic
grid-like causal network which you can
think of as being like a kind of a
one-plus one-dimensional minkowski space
which is therefore nice for doing
uh analysis of special relativity so
this is the particular sequence of
hypergraphs that one sees
for the kind of canonical choice of
updating order for the default choice
of foliation of the causal network that
we can think of as being the foliation
that was seen by an observer in a rest
frame if we now
uh move to a to a boosted foliation so
effectively we take this causal network
foliation
and we tip it so that now we're
considering different collections of
of updating events as being simultaneous
that corresponds to a different possible
updating order
so we get something like this and so for
this updating order you'll see we see a
different sequence of space
of space like hypersurfaces and
therefore a different sequence of
spatial hypographs
so these two evolutions are different
even though they start and end
with the same the same hypergraph this
one takes i think 14 evolution steps
where this one only took
i guess 11 or something i i can't be
bothered to count
something like that anyway the the the
the basic point being of course just by
sort of elementary causal network
geometry when you shift over to this
tipped foliation
it takes more updating steps to move
from the initial spatial hypergraph to
the final one
because there are you know effectively
you because you're having to traverse uh
more more causal edges in the in the
normal direction to your foliation
in order to get from the initial
hypersurface to the final hypersurface
which gives you immediately the
relativistic analog of time dilation
which is not the relativistic analog
sorry the discrete analog
of relativistic time dilation um
uh which of course is completely
unsurprising given that as i say
what what we're really doing when we
construct these foliations is where
we're
we're doing transformations between two
choices of coordination two choices of
observer coordination
uh that is compatible with the lorentz
transformation in the continuum limit of
an arbitrarily large causal network
so we so here we have a way of
constructing something like something
like a lorenz transformation that works
in the discrete case
and in the continuous case where we we
take a limit as the causal network
becomes arbitrarily large it becomes
precisely
the ordinary lorentz transformation so
this kind of this tells you you know
in some sense why why special relativity
has to be true uh with respect to these
buffer model systems it's all just a
consequence
of of causal and variance of the
invariance of the causal network under
different choices of updating order
okay so i'm aware i don't have too much
time left so let me just uh cover
quickly
a kind of an amusing thing that is uh
something that i don't know
i was i was kind of pleased to figure
this out but uh so um
the uh this gives you things like you
know time dilation length contraction
all those other
features of the bulk features of space
time you can work out pretty easily from
looking at these causal networks
one question you might immediately have
is kind of what's the analog of
relativistic time dilation in one of
these systems
uh sorry of sorry what am i i keep using
the wrong words to say not relative
what's the analog of relativistic uh
mass transformation so we you know we've
seen the time dilation case what's the
analog of
the mass transformation so that turns
out to require something a little bit
more abstract
so um what you really have to realize
and again we'll we'll discuss this in
much greater detail in the general
relativity lecture tomorrow
but the basic idea is that um
you can think of the the energy momentum
tensor and relativity as being
in our case as being a measure of the
flux of causal ledgers
through in in the causal network through
a hypersurface of constant x nu so this
is
this is the the analog of the statement
that you know energy momentum in
relativity
is the is the flux of relativistic
momentum uh pmu through a hypersurface
of constant xnew
instead if you pick a hypersurface in
the causal network and you just measure
how many causal edges are being fluxed
through that hypersurface
uh that gives you a way of determining
energy momentum with respect to one of
our systems
and so then you can think of energy as
being you know energy or rest mass or
something is is
is related to the flux of causal edges
through a space like hypersurface
and momentum is therefore course you
know corresponds to the flux of causal
edges through a time-like hypersurface
so then we can ask well how does how
does that notion of energy change
when we make these uh these lorentz
transformations that correspond to
you know boosted you know the correspond
to lorentz boosts for observers and
things like that
and it turns out it's compatible with
with uh relativistic mass transformation
the basic idea being if you think about
an elementary particle as being a sort
of topological obstruction in the causal
network or in the in the hypograph
where uh you know in the toy case you
can think of that as being like a like a
non-planar piece of the network so in
other words
we know that there's this result in in
the foundations of graph theory which is
kuratovsky's theorem
which says that uh you know a graph is
planar if and only if it doesn't contain
a sub graph
that's a subdivision of either k5 the
complete graph on five vertices
or k3 of the the bypassite complete
graph on three plus three vertices
um and so then that means that if and so
so
every effectively every every non-planar
graph its non-planarity can be reduced
into a finite set of occurrences
of k5s and k33s and so turning that idea
on its head
if you have a hypergraph transformation
rule that preserves planarity
then if you have a non-planar structure
if you have a sub graph a subhypograph
that is a subdivision by the k5 or k3
that will be preserved and therefore it
will behave effectively like an
elementary particle it will behave like
a persistent
uh topological obstruction i i should i
i need to conv i need to clarify this is
this is not how we're saying particles
actually work this is just a a very sort
of toy model of this much as the
minkowski norm is a toy model of how the
actual norm works this is a toy model of
how particles might work
um so then so this is an example so this
is the complete graph on five vertices
on the right
and this is the uh the bipartite
complete graph on three plus three
vertices on on the left
and so then if you have if you consider
a hyper a hypograph that's associated
with a
hypergraph transformation rule that's
preserving flanarity these
lumps of k5s or k33s uh that contain
irreducible non-planar crossings of
edges
will be preserved and will act like
effectively elementary particles
and then what we want to know is how do
the how do the effective masses in other
words how does
how does the flux of uh of causal edges
through a space like hypersurface
change when we make a parameterized
boost uh
in the reference frame of the observer
well okay
like i say it's a little bit abstract
but it turns out that the way you can
derive
a relativistic mass transformation and
if i have time i might go into a bit
more detail about how this derivation
works uh tomorrow
is uh in terms of the thing these things
called de bruyne indices
so in in ordinary lambda calculus when
you want to avoid name collisions you
introduce these things called called the
bruyne indices they're effectively ways
of indexing
uh generated variables in in in untyped
lander calculus
so you know if you consider the k and s
combinators in in in combinatory logic
then uh because the the de bruyne index
the the numeral is giving you a sort of
the number of binders that exist between
the variable and the place where it got
bound
so in this case x has an index of two
because there are two binders between
this x and the place where it got
uh represented and in this case here you
know
uh z uh what is it x has uh three
three binders separating this x from
that one and there are there is one
binder separating the z from that z
and two binders separating this y from
that y so we get lambda lambda lambda
three one two one
um so this is this is just uh the the
point of this is is a canonical way of
kind of labeling
uh generated variables with respect to
the lambda calculus we can also use de
bruyne indices
as a way of of labeling vertices uh with
respect to these hypograph systems and
in fact
that's that's effectively what we do
when we have to deal with the case where
there are generated vertices being
produced by one of these substitution
systems
so then uh the the the the basic idea is
when you when you pick a a boosted
foliation through the causal network
because you're applying more updating
events you're applying more rewrite
steps
there are more generated variables that
get produced and so in
just the same way as in an ordinary
rewrite system you know the generated
variables aren't real they're just kind
of artifacts of the particular choice of
rewrite sequence
in just the same way you get a notion of
generated hyper
generated hypernodes that aren't that
are sort of um that are artifacts of the
particular choice of updating order a
particular choice
of of uh foliation and so the more steep
the boosted foliation
the more generated variables there are
because there are more applications of
updating events
and therefore the heavier particles will
appear to be because they will appear to
have more nodes associated with them
not because they actually have nodes
associated with them but because the
nodes have appeared
as an artefact of the updating order uh
in much the same way as they do in in
the context of lambda calculus
and so so that that appearance of
effectively generated variables
as a consequence of the choice of
updating order is the analog of
relativistic mass transformation
with respectable model systems okay just
a final note before we get kicked out of
the zoom meeting for for going over time
um i so i just wanted to mention uh the
one one question you could have is you
know what what
what chain what's the difference between
something like an inertial reference
frame here
and you know one of these crazy
reference frames that we saw earlier
uh like this one that's effectively kind
of oh that has arbitrary curvature where
there's all kinds of weird gravitational
interaction and so on
and effectively what it is and maybe
i'll discuss this you know i i'll
i'll leave the full discussion of this
for tomorrow but effectively the
distinction between
a uh between an inertial reference frame
and a kind of arbitrarily curved
non-inertial reference frame
is one of computability and the the the
inertial reference frame is
corresponding to
the reference frame as seen by a kind of
arbitrarily computationally bounded
observer
and where the curved reference frame is
is one in which the observer has to
perform a a kind of higher order
computation
in order to be able to determine what's
going on but i i don't really have time
to explain that comment in
in more detail here uh maybe we can
discuss it in the in the discussion
section just after this
uh but i i hope to kind of go into more
detail about that later so i'm sorry if
this uh
went a little bit quickly um but we i
you know i'm excited to get on
you know i wanted to cover kind of most
of the of the toy cases of things here
uh because i'm really excited to get on
to the derivation of general relativity
in tomorrow's lecture that's going to
involve you know actually defining not
just a toy case of a minkowski norm but
a proper
sort of space-time norm with respect to
the causal network
and and demonstrating how causal and
variance implies not just
the rent symmetry but also local level
symmetry and therefore by introducing a
notion of curvature
on spatial hypographs and on causal
networks we can derive the full form of
the einstein field equations
and prove that uh sort of wolfen model
systems that are both causal and variant
and which preserve dimension in the
continuum limit therefore have to be
compatible with general relativity
and gravitation and we'll hopefully if
we have time we'll look a bit at some
some of the sort of consequences that
that that uh has for
uh things like inflationary cosmology
and other kinds of things
so um i should probably uh let me stop
sharing and we can uh i don't know how
this
uh erin did we just shift to to another
room to do the to do the
yeah it's on the um on the lecture or
sorry on the schedule we will get kicked
out of here
in four minutes so let's all go ahead
and jump over if you want to do the
group discussion for wolfram physics one
sounds awesome okay right see you there
thank you